there's so many small delicate things
inside this dish and it really speaks to
the simplicity and the beauty but it's
the layers of basil the layers of tomato
the extraction of the tomatoes i'm scott
conant and today we're making roasted
whole snapper with tomatoes basil and
fresh oregano so one of the reasons why
i chose this dish and one of the reasons
why i chose to team up with alzheimer's
was number one my grandmother had
dementia and some of the memories that i
had with my grandmother was really all
of us being around the table around the
thanksgiving table in particular i chose
fish because i feel like part of a
healthy diet is very important for any
brain related disease if you don't have
a really large saute pan i think it's
very easy to just use a larger roasting
pan or the smallest roasting pan that
the fish will fit in you don't want too
much surface area because that sauce
will cook down really quickly so it
really has that beautiful intermingling
of flavors one of the other things that
i like to do instead of holding the fish
and dumping the oil out sometimes i'll
just take a paper towel and absorb all
that excess oil so it doesn't have an
acrid flavor from cooking too much
sometimes that oil can be a little bit
off-putting when you're cooking a
delicate sauce like this as this fish
cooks i love this waft of scents that
you get from the the lemon that's
hitting the oil and the oregano and the
basil there's just a beautiful essence
that comes off of this fish that's a
beautiful perfume so one of the reasons
why i chose to work with alzheimer's
association is because of those memories
that i have from childhood and also the
memories that i'm creating with my own
daughters and with my own family you
know those shareable items being on the
table i have memories of my grandmother
putting you know the turkey down at
thanksgiving kind of that norman
rockwell moment and she couldn't
remember our names much less those
moments those memories that we all
shared together it was difficult to
watch her memory completely slip away of
the things that were important to her
she would go out of her way to make so
much food on thanksgiving it was such a
moment for her to to kind of showcase
the way she loved to cook and i think
those are the things that as they
slipped away from her it made me want to
embrace more with my own family so as i
cook for my children one of the things
that i love how some of these flavors
make me remember different experiences
in my life growing up and my daughters
really love hearing some of those
stories of my childhood it inspires
conversation it inspires that nostalgia
it inspires more memories for my
children so i really want to reflect
that in the food that i cook and how
today when i taste those same things
they hearken back to those memories that
i've built throughout time around the
table is watching my children grow up
around the table is watching my parents
grow old these are things that are such
important moments in my life and i want
to experience them as often as i can and
that's really what it's all about for me
so i really enjoyed making this recipe i
hope you can enjoy it as well around the
table with your friends and loved ones
[Music]
you